[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS: I'm in Jerusalem,
and I'm searching for ecstasy.
[music playing]
My search is for the Na
Nach, a small sect of highly
religious Jews who themselves
are dedicated to the search
for spiritual ecstasy.
Religion as I knew
it was a childhood
battle against
boredom, fidgeting
in the face of archaic text.
But in Jerusalem,
religion can be more
like the misspent nights of
my youth, a God rave right
in the middle of the streets.
[music playing]
A full-on yarmulke
flapping, Na Nach
dance party reverberating
through the ancient Jerusalem
stone.
[music playing]
It's like five o'clock
on a Thursday afternoon.
People are kind of starting
to go home from work.
They're on their way
back from the shops.
And these guys
have felt the need
to come and express
their joy for God
by dancing to happy
house on an old van.
[music playing]
In my old Manchester
clubs, people
weren't this happy
without a little help.
To clarify what's
going on here, I
asked a professor of theology.
CANDIDA MOSS: An ecstatic
religious experience
is an experience in which an
individual feels that they have
sort of left themselves
and have become
one with the universe or God.
They're kind of
outside of themselves
and in connection with something
much bigger than themselves.
[cheering]
[music playing]
It exists in almost
every religious
and spiritual tradition.
It can take lots of
shapes and forms.
And for some people,
when they see
others caught up in the
spirit, looks kind of crazy.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS: So,
this is what you like
to do on a Thursday afternoon?
No, every afternoon, actually.
Every afternoon [inaudible].
Except for Shabbat.
[singing]
TIM SAMUELS: Is everyone
just feeling good because
of the music and faith, or
do you kind of augment that
with some substances, as well?
Are you guys tripping?
Are you high?
- No.
Or you just-- you just--
No, we don't take anything.
I think you don't need all
these substances, you know?
TIM SAMUELS: The Na Nach are
followers of the 19th century
rabbi Nachman of Breslov,
and his 20th century
follower, Rabbi Odessa.
As a Hasidic Jew, Rabbi
Nachman taught his followers
to observe the traditional
dietary restriction
of [inaudible] and grow the hair
at the corners of their heads,
but also encouraged
them to clap,
sing, and dance
during their prayers
to bring them closer to God.
I think there's
a disconnection
between your heart
and your head.
And this connected
together, when
you start dancing,
this action, it
connects everything together.
And you start living.
You start living.
TIM SAMUELS: Mm.
I'm still skeptical.
[music playing]